[Musique]
le jardinage pour vous ça n'est plus un
instant cette session un patient de
decroix de 5 6 ans parce que je voyais
mon père faire d'autres jardins et donc
jardin j'ai trouvé le calme le charme
aussi du potager de la nature les
oiseaux le bruit des abeilles et ça va
être resté pour tout le reste mais je
crois par un acteur comme vous qui vivez
sur les nerfs c'est aussi un très bon
moyen de vous décompresser en
fantastique et c'est il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui sont nerveux s'il voit la
campagne est ici ennuis parce qu'ils ne
savent pas quoi faire de moi j'essaie de
patio de jardin mais c'est très épais
alors en plus je mange tous les légumes
depuis des années le mange mes légumes
vous vous êtes intéressé quand même vous
êtes dans votre jardin à longueur de
journée je ne m'en lisait sauter sur le
jardin tout le temps maintenant à 8
heures je me lève vers 6 heures tous les
jours
alors maintenant on va prendre tenter
des pommes de terre et déjà les plantes
dans les pommes de terre nouvelles sous
des cloches qui viennent de pointer son
arme sans doute un événement le salon
envoie moi j'étais à paris ce je pensais
déjà ça mais en vrai ça trop élevé on va
regarder de petites montées ou vers
d'autres nous prendrait un peu ridicule
vous avez la même passion pour le
potager que pour les fleurs c'est pareil
où les arbres la nature les animaux
s'est pas réveillé et puis et puis aussi
le cinéma le théâtre bien sûr le théâtre
d'abord bien sûr vous avez dit un jour
je crois que le goût du jardinage vous
avez même sauvé la vie ici parce que
j'ai eus vous savez j'ai eue d'une
histoire cardiaque était un peu sévère
paraît-il et c'est ça qui m'a redonné
vie si ici c'est a clairement où je me
suis senti vraiment bien au cellier
ce jardin m'a forcé à avoir de
l'exercice est de marcher parce que le
médecin m'a dit que vous passiez 4 km
par jour
et puis alors savait pas des démarches
comme ça edit et puis pas
parce que les ca comme ça et c'est bien
marché durant leur cycle 2 et comprenez
c'est comme ça il est alors oui parce
qu'à paris je n'aurais jamais fait les 5
km par jour 7 ans diminue avec les
celles que le jardin j'entends -10 vous
en faites le domaine du même beaucoup
plus et ça me fasse à une activité qui
me passionne qui me plaît savez vous
voyez voilà j'ai regardé les eaux
brouillette qui commence seulement il
rien dans une foule avec ses
fournisseurs
ce sont des la vente de l'avant
aujourd'hui qu'il faut que je nettoie
voyez maintenant pour laisser pousser
les autres of le les autres petits je
veux dire voilà 69 si le destin en avait
décidé autrement vous auriez aimé être
horticulteurs oui beaucoup
l'arboriculture tout ce qui est de la
nature j'avais fait mes dd grande étude
la rue bien sûr c'était à refaire je
ferais ça oui parce que le cinéma le
théâtre c'est très très charmant j'aime
beaucoup mais c'est très aléatoire
alors ça atteint les voilà ici à temps
voilà
[Musique]
une salade on va attendre
ah non c'est là où je voulais prendre un
peu de ciboulette il ya des épinards
ça va causer du persil dans l'est dans
les salades en sachet jours s'est offert
pour une salade qui touchent ils
s'avèrent des yeux c'est une aventure là
cela dit vous avez eu un premier record
roma on avance toute chose non là vous
êtes dans votre c'est race 1000 wii à
celui en fait c'est une cire de travail
parce que j'ai pas du tout de serre
d'agrément avec des paniers je suis je
pas le temps et plus la revoir
j'aime bien le cerveau travaille alors
là vous faites à la fois les fleurs et
légumes
oui il ya des plants de légumes
d'asselah des plans des plants de
salades comme il fait mauvais dans les
esprits 6-1 saveur on n'aurait jamais
façon déclare aux filles comme ça ce
sont des géraniums lierres vous savez
tout le monde tend la main j'ai fait la
culture de
un petit jardinières d'une heure je suis
pas plus qu'elle ne suis pas vraiment un
cas les surnoms ce sont vos boutures de
géraniums bois voilà les tomates on
mangera cet été les voiles et voiliers
sont fait remarquer cette chose-là cette
hauteur là mais s'assure sont des
tomates ça ne sont pas d'hybride moi je
n'aime pas les hybrides je ne me fie les
hybrides se sont l'ailier thomas
d'autres frais qui s'appelle la nar
nantes c'est très bon la compagnie a
toujours juré l'yonne géraniums
géraniums voilà et vous pratiquez
l'agriculture biologique
je fais tout tout mon jardin sans sans
produits chimiques
aucun d'ailleurs le jour je me rappelle
aujourd'hui j'en faisais partie rigueur
partout depuis son petit range et j'en
étais pas de mettre des granulés qui dit
des horreurs
le jour où j'ai arrêté ça il y avait
déjà beaucoup moins de pucerons et ça
s'est calmé je ne soyez plus rien les
plants étaient plus malins vous avez
déjà mieux les planteurs et respirer
seul essai commune si vous avez des
pucerons que j'en ai plein la figure du
machin vous allez vous trouvez pas bien
les plantes taille ça allait déjà
beaucoup de ne rien mettre déjà et après
je mets les produits qui sont de la
corne en poudre du sens pau dans du lait
plumes en poudre des plus beaux de woods
de la plume en poudre ça pèse beaucoup
plus lourd déjà que la foudre l'appli
janvier sainte rita bon vous avez
compris ce que je suis dit voilà et puis
alors j'ai dejé du duduk de la poudre
d'os et tout ça me remplace tous les
imbéciles qui sont déserts naturels et
puis du fumier bien entendu mais je le
fais moi-même avec de la deûle à de la
paille et des produits de d'algues
marines
quelles sont les qualités d'un bon
jardinier et bien je crois enfin que
c'est le calme la patience la sérénité
c'est en tout cas pour moi qui suis à un
nerveux ça m'amène tout ça déjà ça me
l'amène dans le jardin jugé comme ça et
c'est toujours tort monsieur je suis
immédiatement comme ça ma faim ça m'a
même du du calme
oui
il
[Musique]